hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are watching
thunderful world which is the uh first
ever showcase event from thunderful
games this video is sponsored by
thunderful games huge thank you to them
for sponsoring this video but it's also
kind of a dream come true for me
whenever anyone sponsors something that
i would have done anyway nobody tell
them don't let them know but if you
don't know thunderful uh the reason that
they came on my radar is because of
deadly premonition 2 and their work on
that which naturally i played on this
channel and had a wonderful time with
but they were probably best known for
steamworld and steamwell dig 2
which is free uh so that's cool
and a bunch of that games are actually
going to be discounted from today which
is november 8th to november 11th so
check them out love to support a um a
smaller publisher
with a lot of really creative games and
they did ask me to ask you to wishlist
their games which mike bithell of
playwatch listen with support and to
check out their steam store i'll leave a
link in the description but uh for now
let's watch this conference i am excited
i think mark hamill is hosting it so
that's insane let's do it hello
and welcome back to luxury what i'm mark
hamill and you're watching hamil's house
you are mark hamill i'm your host mark
hamill somehow you may remember me from
your favorite motion picture or video
game i'm pretty much in everything
though you probably remember how did
they get him
94's wing commander 3.
like a disbelief
oh man hello hey mark hamill how's it
going it's brian well hi brian hey
listen i'm pretty short on time here i
was wondering i think i forgot a book
over at your place uh yesterday do you
think you can go look for it for me
please
hey brian i'm live right now in front of
literally everyone sure marco well i
understand but uh sure mark campbell if
you talk to my camera you are going to
say first name mark last name hamill
small table
oh man
what does this book look like brian it's
pretty big and i guess pretty heavy
he's rocking that you have to be a
little more specific but he plays a
combo book and more of a beefy and
ponderous tome yeah sure i guess i could
describe it as a tone i haven't seen it
he's a good actor brian's doing good
really
remember buddy you leave something in my
house it's mine
i feel like brian's performance is like
maybe better than mark hamill's dark
secrets of the thunderful world
might as well dig into this for your
entertainment and education
i'm cool with it i'm cool with it
world premiere
wave tale the new ip by the creators of
steam world and lost in random that's
exciting available today on stage so
coming to pc and console 2022. lost in
random looks like an exciting hypnotic
hydro adventure i also really enjoyed it
what do we have here oh
there's a trailer
something this is doing something to me
i don't
watching mark hamill
i don't i don't even know how to process
this
like
this
monk hamilton in my industry
before the city sank
before the dirty paws showed up and took
everything away from us
oh that's cool
hey zeus
finally jesus simulator
[Music]
the name of this the gate the game with
the skating oh my god uh jet
[ __ ]
i'm forgetting the name this trevesa
looks awesome
huh
i don't love the art style
but
i feel like that game that looks very
fun wave tail
[Music]
i feel like that would genuinely be fun
to play
um
what am i thinking of
game way you tag oh my god i can't
believe i forgot the name of it
when i could walk on water okay
an epic sci-fi saga where two friends
must stage a rescue let's take a look
it's wild man
that's me let's travel to the distant
lush unspoiled planet of novo
there we meet a young girl named lana
one day
lana is thrown into an epic rescue
mission as an invading robot army
kidnaps her sister
scared and alone she sets off through
the novo wilderness gradually uncovering
a hidden past
before long she meets muay
a stranger i mean this looks beautiful
it proves a handy this is definitely
one of those indie games i'll play on a
sci-fi puzzle adventurous story of
friendship collaboration and trust will
move you more thoroughly and
dream thunderf00t crossed with a
cross with an inside
some minor breath of the wild vibes with
the
way the guardian guys look
yeah that's definitely a game that i
will play
someone in the live chat just said limbo
vibes that is
yeah the inside limbo
down i'm down
[Music]
as long as it's not too long
wow that looks like a pretty good game
i'd play that would you walk apple video
games these days sure are robustly
sophisticated feats of technical sorcery
i remember when video games were just
weird toys with a bunch of knobs and
button nuggets
those were the days
look
speaking of weird
oh my god this is incredible
[Music]
what
walter
what but
[Music]
know what i expected based on the art
[Music]
walter whoa that's pretty
will you stop shouting please
what
[Music]
this is out now i haven't heard of this
game what is
[Music]
about your this
what was the name
walter
walter rebel
what
this looks really good
damn
oh the announcement is is consoles
i feel like i might check that out also
oh dear
one would have to be careful not to get
deadness in a world of rusty metallic
foes thank you my camera that's a great
tip
[Music]
[Music]
segway it was a segway okay okay
very good
[Music]
i did love the first super meat boy but
i've not really felt compelled to play
it since for whatever reason
it's time to meet your maker
get it
oh my
what
okay
that's a good idea let's see what do we
have next
curse to golf
what
shouldn't that be blessed to golf
oh wait he's dead
curse to golf is better
incredible honestly
in cursed golf take on the role of a
recently deceased golf champion who
after a freak accident finds themselves
trapped in golf purgatory in an ironic
twist of fate they must golf their way
through 18 dungeon-like halls to ascend
taking place across four beautiful but
deadly biomes hit satisfying golf shots
to survive the onslaught of golfing
hazards in this exciting new golf-like
adventure that will test any unprepared
sunday driving i can't figure out i told
you about the ace cards your accent are
you australian and it's just like a
strange twin to it
for success in ascending find them in
eternity i always feel like i have an
australian like a spidey sense of like
legendary caddies they will teach you
everything he said australia mysteries
of golf purgatory past their trials gain
their skills
one step closer to ascending and when
you do
maybe do what's wrong as well who are
you sir
i need to look this up i'm sorry
everybody i it annoys people when i do
this but i can't help myself
cost to golf
well that looks like the best darn golf
game but what are they australian oh hi
justin woodward from the mix what's
happening mark hamill i think they're
not in the same room how did you get
into my house my homie brian from
thunderful told me to come through
he says you have some beefy headlights
oh you where are you in the world
hefty
chew high labs you mean
ponderous uh okay they're in kyoto so
they could be
expats you really saved my butt mr
hamill
oh please call me mark hamill i'm sorry
i was speaking of your [ __ ] what's
happening but i got to jump on the first
thing smoking and get back to sweden
peace
he bought it
dear viewer listen carefully it's only a
matter of six to eight weeks before
justin finds his way back to scandinavia
we must plunge forward and hasten our
quest to reveal every video game
possible before the swedish police get
here
and now
this is cute i think it's cute as
quickly as possible a rapid fire magic
attack of video game trailers played
back to back to back we love that we
love that
yeehaw the post-apocalyptic wild west
has never looked so ravaged lock and
load into the very first motor venia
game welcome to the desolation
motormania look at you [ __ ] ghost
adventure like no one look at you
gun-toting coyote warrior on a deadly
path of vengeance tearing through the
desert on a dirt bike pulling off tricks
while sending folks to the afterlife
like a thirsty john wick is just the
start of this epic this is like um this
mad maxi demon nate is causing all sorts
of chaos to make a special birthday
treat for the lord of the underworld in
hell pie
use and abuse nate's trusty sidekick
nugget the synergy between his chained
sheriff will give nate the freedom to
burst through obstacles and enemies any
way he wants
explore the twisted world and turn up
the heat in this 3d platforming
adventure
out of the ring pan and into the fire in
this roguelike where you play a young
rescue officer and fire girl hack and
splash rescue
armed with a trusty axe and
high-pressure fire hose that doubles as
a jet pack respond to emergency calls
across the city
it's up to our courageous fire girl to
uncover the truth as to why these fires
have engulfed the city
the mystery continues
a modern-day point-and-click adventure
follow milder as she receives an
unexpected i do love a point and click i
miss out genre late too hard though like
it was absurd you're not allowed to say
games are too hard people are like well
get good but
they are impossible sometimes with the
blend of real locations history and
myths delve deep into a world that
really i guess i have played some new
ones on like ipad but i didn't love them
so much chips arcade style and tactical
gameplay offers a fresh take on
roguelikes at breakneck speed cutting
through the breach at high speed
zigzagging lasers and dodging explosions
is what to expect from swordship defense
is your best weapon outsmart your
enemies turn the tide of battle by using
your ship's maneuverability to turn
their deadly weapons against them this
high octane thrill ride coupled with
fluid visuals and silky controls will
have your combo meter overflowing
welcome to tinkertown your ultimate
sandbox experience
play solo or grab some friends and go on
hilarious epic multiplayer capers
together a magical land awaits filled
with loot mystery and danger all wrapped
in an ever evolving creative playground
there's also a massive content drop
coming real soon so go mad and create
your own epic story in this pixel
perfect it's pretty sorry i realize i'm
not saying anything i apologize source
of madness a dark action rogue light
this level this yes
powered by procedural generation and ai
machine learning to build very much yes
you encounter gain new skills and magic
absolutely it's cool as hell the
nightmares of the lone lands what
nightmarish odyssey will be thrown at
you next when you try it's an early
access i would like to play this
[Music]
interested in some of those some of them
oh side scrolling independent platform
video game
a rickety metropolis lorded over by
sinister rap it's moody graphics only a
liar wouldn't love
i do always find it interesting when
games play with with kalo like this
[Music]
okay this is definitely limbo vibes
[Music]
and you can see like sort of lost in
random
[Music]
i like the look of the world
[Music]
yeah it looks cool
[Music]
i wonder how they use the lighting like
if it is used to its advantage somewhere
somehow
like
not the lighting sorry i mean the lack
of color
surely at some point there is color
somewhere
nice
this next one's in multicolor
[Music]
they're moving at a great pace i mean
this
we've had aaa conferences that have not
been this sharp
they are
getting through video games which is
what you love to see and they're all
pretty different
[Music]
oh it's like a
like a different version of katamari
like your box delivering katamari
[Music]
oh my the void
hmm what is it is that toga togas i
couldn't see what the name of that was
huh yes you know why they call them
video games tell me because they have
graphics and with confident distinct
visual styles like these i don't know if
that's it you don't even need some
beautiful fine winely hollywood
celebrity to hype up your stuff
[Laughter]
i'm a fan i i'm a big fan of the writing
of this conference i like it
hey mark hamill hey sarah bond what can
i do for you well my friend brian is
asking everyone he knows to drop by and
pick up that tome of secrets from you
and fiona nova is on her way but i was
really hoping that you would reveal the
ghost before she gets there fiona she's
the lead of the gunk well that sounds
delightfully slimy
okay let's see stay tuned for fiona
noble content on this channel everybody
it'll happen the gunk is an epic finish
starring a pair of gritty space haulers
who discover a beautiful planet teeming
with life and alien vegetation until
they discover a parasitic sentient alien
gunk why not just have it actually
written on the book instead of making
him read off the prompter
[Music]
what
that seems like it would make sense
sarah bond also should have memorized
her lying there rather than reading off
the prompter but that's fine
we like sarah bond we'll allow it she's
super cool
voice ronnie the main character in the
gunk
oh she got my friend she's famous oh my
god bonnie is part of a small team of
space explorers looking to make it rich
and they discover uncharted land and
that's when the mystery starts
i'm pretty sure the ship's insurance i'm
more excited about feeling that i am
about so that's saying something
she could talk she'd say she want us to
land and go explore
your quest to unravel this amazing and
beautiful mystery of this forgotten
planet is only just the beginning yeah i
thought this was an idiot xbox title
the fun of voicing ronnie with abigail
turner who plays backs and tapping into
human experiences like joy humor
conflict resolutions and cast symbols
that voice someone else bringing their
dynamics together was really interesting
maybe you should take a look at his code
yesterday he ran all of my tools to the
washing machine
uh yeah
that storm was rough and i don't like
the look of that river
run some diagnostics on bunny just to be
safe this looks different to the way it
looked in the original trailers official
[Music]
the character's desperate situation the
tension of long-haul space travel
financial allergies man only get more
complicated sorry everybody dropped off
to this alien world for the first time
together and i really can't wait for you
all to experience the world of the gunk
fiona
what a mesmerizing trailer sarah bond
where can i find such a gooey treat well
mark hamill you are in luck the gunk is
being hello they call him mock camel
it's so funny
and xbox game pass in december she for
sure should have read those lines candid
or like not be reading them fiona nova's
arrived uh-oh gotta go make sure fiona
gets the book mark hamill bye sheridan
well
i guess my next guest
i really should start locking my front
door
hey wait didn't i just hear your voice
in the gunk yes you did i play the lead
role oh i love your work hey i love your
work well so okay i'm here because brian
told me that i have to retrieve some
kind of tome uh and i we can't get a
hold of justin woodward from the mix uh
was it uh this book
i believe it is
all right
it's an accomplishment oh my god listen
i gotta bounce so talk to you later mark
goodbye fiona nova i love her so much
she's one of my favorite people on the
entire planet and let me just say
if you and i have no apologies if you're
watching this
watching fiona do a conference as a
professional
not that she's not a professional super
accomplished at a lot of cool creative
stuff especially for her age she's
awesome it's really funny because of the
stuff that actually comes out of fiona's
mouth most of the time
look at her girl but like i'm so used to
like seeing her and immediately being
like oh my god
it's just
i love her she's fantastic i'm gonna
play the [ __ ] out of that game
mark i've called you like 17 times he's
a good actor somebody hooked brian up
with everyone here right now i mean i
know you have the book
whatever you do do not turn to the final
page and why shouldn't i
everyone has a right to see mark hammond
if you turn to that page yeah sure read
it up and now
you will announce to the world
thunderful's greatest game yet dead of
premonition three
people have a right to know daily
promotion three mark hamill listen to me
please don't i think it's probably gonna
be um no
steamworld
the thrilling conclusion to
deadly primitive ah
[Music]
it doesn't look like york but it could
be in the future it could be set in the
future at some point
you know
in case you didn't know
[Music]
interesting
so thank you for watching thunderful
world i wonder what that is exactly that
we are announcing our news looks like a
completely different genre we are going
to make one of the most beloved games in
the steamworld series steam will dig 2
free for download for a limited time
yeah that's cool to find out how and
where to get the game check out our
website and our social media channels
that's it for me for this time i hope
you had a thunderful time together he's
a really good presenter man he's great
[Music]
i think that they did a pretty good job
they did a pretty good job
a lot of variety of games there there
was like i think three that really stood
out to me that i would want to check out
um which is
pretty standard stuff
um but i feel like that
that wasn't at all
like full of
terrible video game conference cliches
so for their first conference ah rob
talbot i worked with him rob's great
big fan of rob's wife
he's like all my friends
not that i'm not a fan of
rob that's besides the point fiona was
there mark hamill was there um
i thought that was neat yeah um so of
course this is a sponsored video but
that none of my opinions are ever
altered by any of that is all my
reactions would be completely genuine
and i would think expected based on
every other reaction that i've ever done
um obviously goes without saying but
just in case anybody had any questions
but yes they did ask me to tell you to
go wishlist their games if you like them
and then when you follow them on social
media to be notified of when the games
come out um again apologies for the
allergies if i was a little bit quiet
because i also have asthma just
real dusty right now and that is not
good for my entire sort of face region
it's a real shame um but yes huge thank
you to thought of all performing this
video check out the link in the
description if you want to find out more
and just a big thank you to mark hamill
just
wow